HEY !
Aujourd'hui on va
à un jeu vidéo
fait par quelqu'un
qui est en école
de gamedesign
ça présage que du bon.
Il a mit 4 mois
à développer le jeu
C'est fait avec le moteur source
Donc le moteur de Counter-Strike Source
d'où le nom.Euh.....source
et il a joint au jeu un petit synopsis
parce qu'il sait que j'ai du mal à chaque fois
à introduire les jeux.
Il m'a aidé merci beaucoup.
Et il manque... y'a pas  la fin de la phrase
C'est pas grave merci pour ce petit synopsis c'est parti !
Ah c'est trop bien fait,  c'est trop cool mec
ooooh, la vache!
"Appuie sur E pour fermer tes yeux LUCAS depeche!!"
"RIRE"
Let's go!
Je vais retourner dans le passé du coup?
Oh merde!
Oh le bad.
ça va sur moi ça, c'est en train d'aller sur moi
Hiiiiiiiiii!
Ah?
Eh ouais, j'étais pas mort!
OK
Direction le passé
Attend c'est trop cool!
Ils ont même fait le doublage des personnages et tout
C'est un super cadeau de Noël que vous m'avez fait là
Je suis hyper heureux
Ok on se réveille
Ah! ça tue sa mère (les oreilles) .
Ouah...
What the fuck ? C'est ma chambre ça ?
Attends, c'est ... je suis pas comme ça dans ma chambre
C'est quoi ça ?
C'est la bromance mon gars.
D'où j'ai un cadre
Avec une photo de moi et Micka
Comme ça dans ma chambre.
Imprimée en énorme
Micka je t'aime bien mais
Ouais t'es où, t'es où mon pote ?
OK
Ok, ok je prends le talkie
tu vas me guider, je t'écoute
totalement
on se croirait dans DieHard.
C'est ouf !
C'est parti !
Bah, tu me connais.
OK.
Ouais grave.
Hop là!
Mais bien sûr !
Bon comment on sort de là ?
TOUSSE
Je te jure que non.
ça marchait pas.
J'étais friendzoné tout de suite
Ouais de ouf!
Eh mec, c'est pas comme ça chez moi en vrai
Moi c'est
je fais un seul gros tas.
Voila
Ok j'ouvre la porte
Putain, je suis sous-pression mon gars !
Des escaliers qui montent
Très bien
Eh ça ressemble
à mon..
Eh mais mec
ils se sont basés
pour de vrai, sur la où j'habitais
avant, dans la maison où
j'habitais avant
C'étais comme ça sauf que
sauf que les portes étaient un peu plus loin.
Putain!C'est trop marrant mec.
ça c'était la porte des toilettes
Mais attends mec, c'est exactement..
comme chez moi.
comme les...
Mais mec c'est ouf!
Ça c'est les toilettes.
C'est ... mec c'est exactement ça
Et là à droite , normalement c'est mon bureau.
Et ça c'est exactement... putain les gars vous ...
Franchement. Oh ça me touche jsuis ému franchement.
Allez! On continue là bref on est en période de... de crise .
Hein ... c'est bien là ou y'a le frigo .
Putain! Mais c'est incroyable
Nan, sans déconner, c'est ouf !
Bon, alors faut que j'aille où ?
Faut que j'ouvre le frigo et que je me fasse un petit euh... un ptit steak posé ?
Mais même ce tacos, c'était souvent dans mon frigo.
Grosse blague... Grosse blague...
Nan pas déconner non plus !
Ok, alors du coup faut que je fasse quoi ?
Ah ça je l'avais pas, j'aurai bien aimé mais j'avoue j'avais pas ça !
Y'a des nouilles... Des... Bon tout ce qu'on aime! De la pizza...
A mec j'avoue.
Hey...Tu critique pas mon chez moi putain !
Parce que t'as pris un malin plaisir à le modéliser !
Nan en plus pour de vrai je crois que
j'ai jamais fait des fêtes comme ça chez moi.
Pour de vrai!
Voila petite confession... Y'a même l'arbre à chat!
Mais Jumbo il va être dessus!
Ma mission c'est de trouvé Jumbo à l'heure qu'il est.
Putain c'est hyper fidèle
même ces étagères, l'arbre à chat...
Ça me fait super bizarre en fait
de voir vraiment mon chez moi
hyper... Enfin reproduit euh... De manière hyper fidèle
Dans... Mais dans un jeu!
Oh Yannou!
Attends le gars est amoureux de ces amis quoi!
Il s'endort en pensant à eux chaque soirs,
il les mets dans des cadres et tout c'est terrible.
Alors Jumbo, t'es où mec ?
Par contre, il faut que je trouve Jumbo.
JUMBO !
Viens là!
Bon Jumbo t'es où ?
Derrière le canapé ?
Nan?
Où il se cacherait...Oh putain...
Où il se cacherait Jumbo ?
Oh il est la je l'ai trouvé! Mais il est sur un cadre.
C'est ça ?
Ah non j'ai juste cassé le cadre et la photo reste au mur.
Putain pas mal le cadre hein.
Il y'a le lait. Il est pas en train de percer les bouteilles de lait ?
Non c'est bon.
Dans la poubelle ? Non putain c'est le bordel mon gars!
Il est dans mon bureau ?
Voix off: "Ton bureau est fermé, il faut à tout pris
que tu trouve la clé parce que c'est la que tu dois aller."
Aaaaaaaaah
Et j'aurai mis où la clé ?
Où... Où aurai-je mis la clé mon gars ?
Tiens je vais me servir de ça pour un peu déblayer tout ça là.
Où est la clé ?!
Peut être dans la porte d'en face.
Ah bas voila.
C'est quoi ça ?
Ah putain...
En plus cette pièce normalement c'est une vielle pièce sombre
avec zéro fenêtre où j'étends le linges quoi.
Et là c'est devenu une pièce toute belle.
Voila. Du mec qui voue un culte pour Cyprien!
Dans les chiottes hein. Dans les chiottes les portraits de Cyprien!
Bon en tout cas il y'a pas de clés dans les chiottes
C'est de belles chiottes, vraiment très très belle!
Mais il y a vraiment pas la clé
Peut être dans ma chambre hein, je pense qu'elle est dans la chambre, la clé.
Je pense que je l'ai raté mais elle doivent être vers là.
Elle doit être dans tout ce bordel putain,
mais pourquoi j'ai pas rangé la chambre dans mon jeu.
Normalement je la range toujours en plus.
C'est faux.
Où est la clé ?!
Montre moi la voie, jeune pastèque, la voie de la clé stp.
Ooooh! Mais elle est là! Putain!
Mon gars, j'ai mis tellement de temps à trouver cette putain de clé.
*Rire* Ça ma rendu ouf!
Bon alors... Olala... Putain mec c'est fidèle de ouf! C'est abusé!
La giraffe!
Voix off: "Ne me demande pas comment je le sais hein
mais derrière c'est deux cartons, tu trouveras un passage secret,
et je suis quasi sûr qu'on le retrouvera là-bas."
Ok, d'accord. Il m'a dit qu'il y'avait un passage derrière les deux carton
qu'il y a là bas, c'est ça ?
Ouais.
C'est quoi ça ?
Pourquoi des fois il commence à s'ouvrir et des fois il s'ouvre plus ?
D'accord il faut mettre du poids la dessus.
Ah c'est ça, ok il faut juste mettre du poids la dessus
Ah c'est vrai que Jumbo il fait 200kg, il a pu l'ouvrir facile.
Qu'es-ce-que je peut mettre de lourd ? Un écran dessus?
Ah...
Voix off: "Bien... J'avais jamais remarqué ça."
On est bon.
Let's go!
Jumbo ?
C'est vrai ?
Mais c'est mon chat! On dirait que c'est ton chat.
Hey... Si il y'a un monstre, les gars, j'vous tue, j'vous tue!
Oh putain...
C'est bon. Une bouteille de... Qu'es-ce-que...
Y'a quoi en bas ? Y'a Jumbo ? Jumbo ?
"Contaminated Area"
Oh c'est super bas.
Ah la bouteille qui allume toutes les lumières une par une.
Let's go!
Jumbo ?
Woaw.
Ok.
On se retrouve en bas.
Jumbo ?
Ah c'es lui ? C'est lui qui court!
Jumbo, il c'est barré, mais attends moi Jumbo!
Je vous dit en tout cas il y'avait pas un bunker sous ma maison.
Ça y'en avait pas!
"Secure access"
Euh... Y'a un truc à branché, quelque chose du genre je suppose?
C'est là bas, c'est de l'autre coté,
Faudrait que j'accède à ce bouton ou peut être que je lance truc dessus
genre ça. Je pense que c'est ça. Ah non c'est trop lourd.
En tout cas, attends ça peut être je peux
Oooooh
Allez ouvre toi. J'ai peur, je commence vraiment à flipper les gars
Ah ça fait beaucoup de bruit ça! Allez on dégage.
On dégage mon gars
Jumbo il est parti... Je sais plus où...
Oh putain... Je vais mourir!
Attends, faut que tourne ça.
Je peux pas passer,
parce que le "power" est "on",
et le "power" il est relié... Là bas.
C'est bon, il s'est arrêté.
Ok, ça l'a arrêté, on va pouvoir y'aller.
Ok.
Y'a un mec en face,
c'est Slender ?!
Y'a Slender mec, attends attends, ça va me...
Wooooow!
What the fuck!
Les gars!
C'est pas gentil...
C'est pas gentil du tout de me faire ça.
Pourquoi ?
Jumbo ?
Oh putain ça y'est on part dans un délire mon gars,
il est où Jumbo ?
Moi je veux Jumbo, moi!
Attends...
Il va me courir après ?
J'ai peur, je me casse.
Dans le doute je perd pas de temps, je me tire.
Dis moi que c'est ouvert...
Bas nan! Bas nan c'est pas ouvert pourquoi ce serai ouvert ?
Ce serai trop facile!
Là ? Ouais
Ah ouais et là j'arrive dans... Ah une combinaison!
Je peux la mettre ?
Ok c'est bon.
Oh putain...
"F" pour allumer la lampe torche, c'est allumé les gars.
Jumbo !
Euh on arrive dans un truc de gestion...
Moi je touche à tout, j'appuie sur "E", sur tout.
"Que pasa?" (Que se passe-t-il)
Voix off:"Squeezie aujourd'hui tu crève."
Aaaah !!!! La lumière, elle s'est éteint en plus arrêter!
Oh pu****, tout à péter, tout à péter.
Ok bas on y va, j'ai compris, ok d'accord ça s'effondre sur moi.
Je peux y aller ?
C'est un zombie ?!
Ah! Et en plus je brûle...Ah... Comment je fait ?
Il va tomber avant ?
Mais oui il va tomber avant, c'est sûr!
Aaaah pu****! J'avais des doutes ça m'a soulagé de le voir tomber ce c**!
Allez on se casse.
C'est un parcours du combattant mon gars,
et Jumbo, il à fait tout ça au calme, il est où ? Jumbo ?!
Il y'a... Qui c'est ?
Oh.
Il est vivant lui...
*Bruit de lampe qui se casse*
Enc*** pu****, je savais.
Je suis sûr, t'es vivant. Dans le doute, dans le doute, je te dégomme!
Ok, j'ai activé l'alarme du coup les portes se... Se réouvrent. Aller on y va.
Ok faut que je casse les trucs,
Ah on peut casser les portes je savais pas.
Normalement enfaite le but c'est que j'aille là bas,
Mais le blême c'est que la porte ne s'ouvre pas.
Bah les amis, je sèche complètement, sur cette partie la euh du niveau,
donc je propose qu'on appelle le créateur du jeu.
Ça va être drôle ça!
J'espère qu'il va répondre sinon on va rester bloqué longtemps.
Téléphone:"Allo"
Allo Benjamin ?
Téléphone:"Ouais"
C'est Squeezie...
Oh il me reconnais.
Comment tu va ?
Téléphone:"Je reconnais la voix comme ça"
Ça va mec ?
Téléphone:"Ça va et toi ?"
Bien...
Ecoute, très bien. Euh... Les gens te dise bonjour, je suis actuellement
en train de tourner une vidéo sur ton jeu,
et je suis bloqué.
Téléphone:"Ah bonjour tout le monde."
Je suis bloqué au moment où il y a un zombie coupé en deux entre deux portes
et qu'il faut débloquer la porte à l'autre bout du couloir...
Téléphone:"T'es bloqué à cet endroit la ? Ah ben c'est la dernière énigme."
C'est vrai ?
Téléphone:"En fait, c'est une sorte de résumé de toutes les énigmes que t'a eu avant,
il y a de petites étincelles qui sortent de la..."
Ouais...
Téléphone:"Tu les vois ?"
Ouais absolument.
Téléphone:"Ça veut dire que c'est comme le principe du ventilateur."
Ouais mais je sais plus...Faut mettre de la fumée...C'était quoi le principe du ventilateur ?
Le mec amnésique.
Téléphone:"En gros, t'a un court-circuit à faire."
Un court-circuit à faire ?
Téléphone:"Dans le ventilateur, t'avais balancé une canette, normalement ?"
Ouais c'est ça.
Téléphone:"Et ben c'est pareil, faut refaire un court-circuit."
Bon je me démerde avec cette info et si je n'y arrive pas je te rappelle ok ?
Téléphone:"Ok"
*Rire*Merci mec.
C'est drôle pu****.
Eh!! Je veux cette option sur tous les jeux,
quand je suis bloqué dans The Last Guardian, j'appelle les mecs qui ont développé :
"Oui j'ai un blême."
C'est un mixte de toutes les énigmes
Et... Il... Il... C'est bien un concepteur de jeux ça! Il veut pas nous balancer le...
le truc. Bon alors attends on va lancer ça dessus.
Ok, ça a cassé, et y'a trois... C'est dans l'ordre.
Ok, faut... Je pense y'a un ordre à faire j'veux dire. Pu**** j'arrive plus à parler.
Et de un, et de deux et de trois...
Oh.
Et ben voilà
Ben je crois que j'ai eu de la chatte,
puisque ça a marcher mec.
Euh...
Non, attends attends je me suis peut être enflammé, faut que je les tue ?
C'est bon, ok ok faut juste que je les tue, pu**** j'ai eu peur.
C'est ça l'énigme ? Aie! C'est se bastonner comme on sait bien le faire ?
On se bat il nous reste de la vie, le dernier coup en slow motion.
Et on passe, est-ce qu'on va rejoindre Jumbo ?
Allo ?
Ah non on était bien dans le passé.
Aaaaaah non c'est la fin.
C'est bel et bien la fin, on a même pas pu voir Jumbo.
Bravo Benjamin, mec c'était énorme pu****,c'était tellement cool, je suis super content,
merci d'avoir pris le temps de faire ça, 4 mois, j'espère que tu n'as pas raté tes études pour autant,
Parce que tu as dû y passer beaucoup de temps et j'espère que ça ne t'as pas pris du temps
sur le temps que tu consacres à tes devoirs.
Eh ben, n'hésite pas à aimer la vidéo si ça t'as plu, moi je suis tout ému 1000 merci, c'était génial.
Peut être qu'il y aura un chapitre 2 dans 4 ou 6 mois du coup, et ben j'ai hâte mon gars!
Aller merci d'avoir regarder la vidéo, on se retrouve très vite dans une prochaine, ciao tout le monde...
Non.